[Music]
my name is Fred wolf this is our Pitta
and we are from streak which is a
start-up of about 40 people based here
in San Francisco
and yeah we're basically this talk we're
really talking about two things one is
this host of managed databases on Google
cloud and the second is sort of how
we're building our business on top of
them and so it's probably helpful to
start with like what our business what
our product is so basically streak is an
organizational tool on top of Gmail so
the way this works behind the scenes is
we ship a Chrome extension that just
modifies the Gmail UI to add in sort of
organization on top of it we have what's
called a pipeline which might be if
you're in sales might be a list of your
sales deals and the stage they're in
whether they're leads whether they're
closed that kind of thing if you're in
support might be support tickets you
know people use this for hiring business
development basically the key thing here
is it's organization on top of email and
like why is that important
so there's a bunch of different tools
within your organization for sort of
making an organization better there's
things like hangouts chatter slack
there's things like project management
tools but once you get outside of an
organization basically everybody uses
email just because everybody has it and
so this the key things that streak adds
so we have what's called a pipeline and
you add boxes which might be sales deals
or support tickets and in addition to
just like organizing your emails so it
when you look at your emails in your
inbox you can sort of see which deals or
support tickets they're associated with
we can also add sort of structured
metadata so things like you know what
stage the deals in who's involved who's
like the point of contact how long it's
been since the last follow-up and all of
that kind of stuff so we're moves to
talk about technology here rather than a
product demo but I just sort of want to
give like a motivating example of sort
of what we're storing in these databases
well and so here we're gonna be talking
about
our database journey and just to give
you a like a little bit of preview sort
of situate everything we started off on
the cloud datastore we're going to be
talking about cloud fire store which is
datastore sort of spiritual successor
and then we're gonna focus in on sort of
one particular problem that we call the
email metadata problem and how we're
building some new product features that
caused us to reach for cloud spanner and
cloud BigTable sort of some of the newer
hosted database technologies so now I
want to give it over to our pita to chat
about our use of cloud datastore and
cloud fire store all right that's a cut
datastore the way we're going to be
talking about the databases is just give
you a little bit of an introduction why
we chose that database service our
takeaways from using that service and
how are our data needs evolved to want a
newer solution so datastore it's a no
sequel document store your data is
organized into documents call entities
which are basically objects that are
accessed via a key or an index value and
the entities similar entities are
grouped as kinds which is like a table
in a relational model entities have
fields called properties and which are
basically the fields the values you get
in built to and built indexes on each of
the properties for an entity there are
no joins or aggregate queries for
datastore
there's the gql which is a query
language for for datastore but the
complex are joints and aggregate
operations are not supported but there's
a simple filtering is it's possible why
we chose it so back when streak was
started it was started on App Engine so
the only database offering at the time
was on Google Cloud was datastore so it
made sense to co-locate our database
with our server stack on Google Cloud
but even so we think it's an excellent
choice for if you're starting out with a
new product or service and that is
because it gives you a lot of
flexibility to evolve your schema and
what that means what data store is with
entities as I said they have different
properties you have you can have the
same properties across entities can be
completely different the number of
properties the even the data types for
the same properties can be different so
it gives you a lot of freedom to just
just build your features and evolve your
schema as you go of course the other
reason we we love datastore is it's a
managed service no ops it Auto scales
Auto replicates Google's SRS handle
availability you don't have to worry
about provisioning capacity upfront and
you just really just throw data at it
and it would just grow with your service
and so back that back then there was one
candidate and over ten years later we
have about 15 terabytes of data on
datastore all our application data is on
it and we found it to be do perform
predictably and have predictable kind of
challenges and solutions so working with
datastore so some concepts that we found
our key to to work most effectively with
datastore one is entity groups so as I
was saying your data is organized into
entities and multiple entities if they
belong to one entity group you can have
a transaction across multiple entities
so you basically want to have your most
highly correlated data in one entity
group so it can be a user profile and so
on at Streak we have the smallest unit
of work is a box so a box can have
different threads of emails notes
comments and a lot of other custom
fields
and so a boxes can be put into pipelines
which are shared across teams and the
teams belong to an organization so the
way you design your energy groups will
have consequences on throughput and
consistency so with for our case we have
four if you want to update boxes we have
our Energy Group set to organization
level which is which means we have a lot
a lower number of energy groups what
that does is so energy groups are also
units of consistency which means a query
against a energy group will always give
you strongly consistent results also
with the transaction
they will always you know your asset
transaction properties will be applied
when you're using energy groups they're
also stored all entities within an
entity group Google stores them
physically close together so your
minimal i/o reads are really fast so
when in our example with boxes when the
energy group is set to an organization
level with one query against an entity
group you get a high volume of entities
but their limit their limits on how many
entity groups
how many writes you can have per entity
group per second which is set to you can
only have one right currently in
datastore per second per entity group
and I'll talk about the consequences of
that in a second the other things that
we found useful working with datastore
as we use objectify which is a Java data
access API that that makes using
datastore really easy the example at the
bottom where you have annotations to
work with entities indexes and so on has
been really useful we use JSON and
Jackson annotations for a serialization
and deserialization then some of the
challenges as I was saying at the write
throughput rate for entity groups is
in datastore is set to one per second so
ideally you want to have really small
entity groups so that you are not
writing more than one per once per
second in our case organizations
pipelines can have hundreds and
thousands of boxes so for example if
you're trying to update multiple boxes
in our case in a pipeline then it can be
tens of thousands of writes against one
entity group so it can cause a lot of
contention and again something to keep
in mind entity group relationships are
are permanent you cannot change them
unless you delete all the entities and
recreate them in a new entity group so
that is a challenge contention as we're
growing we have larger and larger
customers that has been a big challenge
again boxes the way our schema has
evolved there's a lot of child objects
that we have with boxes and now that
they all belong to the same entity group
but transactions are limited to 500
entities per transaction so when you
have cascading rights that also becomes
kind of a performance bottleneck also
another limit to keep in mind there's
you transactions can be are limited only
to twenty-five entity groups so again
you want to figure out your key design
so that you're finding the right balance
between your consistency and throughput
and then client side views so as you saw
in the first graphic we have we present
this spreadsheet layout to your users
and we we offer complex filtering
grouping and sorting and not being able
to do that data store not providing that
out of the box we have to shift this
responsibility to the application code
which of course increases the complexity
and debugging complexity and so on so
not having joints as we as we grow
larger we really miss having all those
features
out of the box which will be which would
be part of a relational database cloud
fire store fire store is the latest
latest version of data store there's two
modes here real-time and data store mode
data store mode fire store and data
store mode is backwards compatible with
cloud data store but it doesn't have
some of the newer features that
real-time fire store has like real-time
updates there's rich mobile and web
client libraries so fire store is
supposed to be a drop-in replacement for
data store and and the migration to it
to fire store is supposed to be
automatic without any downtime so we're
really excited about that basically fire
store has a spanner back in which so
with the say it with the data store
features in the front end so you get a
strongly consistent layer in the back
end and this eliminates some of our
biggest pain points with data store one
we have strongly consistent results
throughout and the entity group
restrictions that I talked about 25
entity groups per transaction and the
write throughput limit of one per second
we don't have we don't have that with
fire store anymore we're hoping to
upgrade soon and yeah all right so we
talked about how we felt the need for a
fully relational model for our
application data and there's a new
feature that that would work we worked
on and it we call it the metadata
problem so I'm sure all of you had this
problem where somebody forgot to hit
reply all in an email and then you got
forward of that email and then now you
have a lot of redundant emails and
emails just in reverse chronological
order and it's just it's it's just not
very elegant so and also there can be
problems with permission sensitive email
that you were not supposed to receive
ends up in your inbox
so strict solution to that is having a
unified unified view of of emails across
a team so in this example you have the
top three emails were not addressed to
me but as you can see they're shared
from my co-workers inboxes so you get
kind of this elegant view of the email
and which is controlled by a permission
model so this looks really good in the
UI but on the back end it's kind of a
complex graph traversal problem so we
want to answer questions like which
which co-workers of mine have interacted
with this particular prospect over email
or for this email what are the other
emails on this thread that are not in my
inbox but in my co-workers and boxes so
the solution to that we came up with
with a graph solution where your nodes
are either a person or an email an
organization or a domain or an email
message and the the email messages are
connected if they're on the same thread
so if I emailed you and then you
forwarded the email to somebody else we
can trace those emails and give you a
unified view and then two emails are
also connected if they are if they are
the same email but they're the part of
different people's inboxes they're
connected by something that is called an
RFC ID with with Gmail so same message
but different inboxes so this this
obviously helps us to answer the
questions and create a unified view that
can be shared across a team to talk
about how we we approach this problem
solving this and the relational model
needs that friend great real quick
before I go on to our solution
I just want to yeah like build on what
are Peter was saying so this is like a
pretty challenging graph database
problem like you have to really
understand
this like sort of course of an email
thread or a course of like connected
email threads across different people's
inboxes your organization you might have
to hit hundreds of different inboxes
I'm sure you've all been on these like
horrible reply-all threads that have
like you're not just hundreds of people
on the company in the company but like
you know thousands of you know emails
one should count although it'll you know
some email chains and so there's kind of
this graph database problem but it's
also pretty challenging for a couple
reasons technically so one is you have
to be able to do all of these edge
traversals quickly you there may be a
lot of you know emails are sort of nodes
from the graph problem and as our pet I
mentioned permissions are a huge deal
right email can be really sensitive you
could have password reset emails you can
have manager giving you know targeted
feedback to a report that might not be
you know generally consumable they're
just like all these ways they can go
horribly wrong if you don't have a
strong permissions model and the kind of
what this means is we have to traverse
this graph and there's pretty there's
pretty big challenges if we try and pre
compute a lot of this stuff you know
that that's served normally the sort of
distributed systems way out is you just
like denormalize a bunch of stuff in
advance and in this case we both you
know really needed to compute it it read
time to make sure that we're getting
permissions right even if somebody just
changed some permissions and this is all
happening within the context of viewing
emails in Gmail and you know the whole
premise of Gmail is that it's really
fast people expect their emails to just
like load quickly even if they're
searching their whole inbox and we're
expanding that to like letting you
search you know parts of not just your
inbox but your everybody in your
company's inbox possibly so challenging
technical problem looking at the backend
this is actually across our entire user
base we have about 30 terabytes of just
email metadata so that's like we're not
looking at the contents of email we
don't really want to but just looking at
like who the emails from who it's to the
sort of information we need to compute
these edges
and so we evaluated a bunch of different
database products there's a lot of
graphs specific database products on the
market but we really you know all else
being equal we wanted something that had
this property where it was managed by
Google we have a very small operational
team we basically have roughly three
infrastructure engineers depending on
how you slice different people's time
and being able to offload some of that
like availability and sharding work to
Google s re really seems like a good
trade-off dummest so we looked at a
bunch of different options and we ended
up this was our first use case for cloud
spanner
so cloud spanner I think it's about a
year old at this point maybe a little
bit more but the key things about it
sort of looking at just the product in
general it is a globally consistent
relational database and so what does
that mean it supports you know the
sequel language that you you don't know
and possibly love or hate depending on
what you've done with it and it has what
I affectionately call the magic clock
thing and the magic clock is basically
you know for years and years and years
sort of there was always this sort of
introductory paragraph in every
distributed systems paper which
basically said something like we know
clocks are unreliable and go back in
time and have jumps you know and the
network's unreliable and may have you
know horrible latency and everybody just
sort of took it as a premise that you
sort of couldn't rely on clocks and they
were you know trying to lead you astray
and so the the spanner white paper that
came out a while back and now the cloud
spanner product is built on this idea of
hey what if instead of like sort of
accepting this as a premise we just made
the clocks roughly reliable and there's
like a bunch of a bunch of effort in
terms of installing in atomic clocks and
all the data centers there's a bunch of
effort in terms of like setting up the
networking and there's a bunch of effort
in terms of the statistics of like
setting error bars on timing but the
outcome of it is the cloud spanner you
know says on the tin and it's actually
true like we're using it and anger it is
globally consistent so
basically this means that you know going
back to the stuff that are patted about
with datastore you don't have to
pre-select particular entity groups you
don't have to say these are the things
that I'd like to do transactions on
beforehand you just when you go to
actually update entities it looks at
what in these you've queried and you
only have transactional conflicts if if
you are actually modifying things that
we wrought that were all so you know
queried by other queries so it's like
just a set of stuff that our actual real
transaction conflicts so you know this
is great
globally consistent sequel you know it
has you know really great transactions
and you know some of you who are sort of
thinking this through might say you know
but wait you know email itself isn't
consistent why do you care about
consistency you know I might send you an
email and you know all the time we see
emails taking you know ten minutes
thirty minutes to get delivered why do
we care about the database being
consistent and the answer is it's it
goes back to that sort of operational
ease it means that when we have our
syncing logic we can you know sync the
data we can we can build these indexes
to power these graph queries and we
don't have to worry that you know just
think it's partially committed we can
just say hey all of this should be
committed in the transaction and it just
like you know it's either all committed
or not committed and this just means
that our you know indexing pipeline
that's processing a lot of email was
basically written by you know it
basically took one engineer about half
time working on it for a month or so it
was like really for the scale of
distributed system you know when we were
planning out the work we're like hey we
probably need to you know have at least
two people on this for a quarter and
just by you know relying on the spanner
transactionality to deal with a lot of
the edge cases we were able to just like
get it out and get it you know in
customers hands much more quickly and so
building
that operational ease there's a lot of
other sort of really nice features in
that area around spanner so in a
previous life I've managed a couple of
like on premise sequel databases and
sort of all of those operational things
that just sort of fill DBAs with carer
things like adding or removing columns
adding and removing indexes both they're
like pretty easy to do and and and
they're also there's a pretty good sort
of task planner that makes sure that
even if you add and remove a bunch of
columns it doesn't interfere with your
actual transactional workload so that's
you know all pretty nice things to have
even if our underlying data isn't
necessarily super dependent on this
strong consistency and so let's you know
I've been singing its praises generally
let's talk about how it actually works
in practice so this is in the cloud
console the schema for one of our tables
in production and this table is what we
call message mailboxes and so that's if
you remember the sort of graph nodes
there were some things that are
dependent on the message itself you know
which Gmail threads and which other
messages have the same sort of message
ID header to figure it out between
inboxes but there's also stuff that's
dependent on who the message is
addressed to or who it's from or who's
on the CC list and message mailboxes has
one row per person on a message so if I
send a message to you the message the
version of the message in my inbox would
have two message mail boxes rows one for
me and one for you and key things here
so you see at the top it says that this
this table is interleaved in messages
interleaved tables is this feature in
cloud spanner that lets you sort of have
really great performance for stuff that
you know should be co-located together
and so here most of the time that we're
querying you know who's on a particular
message we also care about what message
they're on and so here we've interleaved
message mailboxes and messages and that
means
if I want to do an index filter on you
know all the messages that correspond to
a particular email address you know that
a particular email address was part of
so let's say in the street product we
want to be able to show all of your
communication with a particular Sales
Lead across the organization
I can query on mailbox email and then do
a very quick join a very performant join
with the messages table to get things
like what was the subject of that email
or like these other these other
properties that sort of if you were
doing a more traditional distributed
system you might have to denormalize and
waste a lot of space to sort of get
performant and then and so you know we
use interleaved rows a bunch we one
other interesting things so there's
you'll see these sort of weird is BCC or
is CC boolean fields at the bottom and
so that's basically saying hey is this
particular email address in the BCC line
is it in the CC line like how are they
connected to this message and the the
interesting thing there those rows
actually have two values which you might
expect from a boolean but those values
are actually true or null and so like
why are we doing this
so spanner actually has this ability to
have what are called null filtered
indexes so if you're coming from like
Postgres or I'm sure Microsoft sequel
server has the similar thing you might
be familiar with this concept of partial
indexes and there that means that we can
create an index that's just you know is
this person on the from line or are they
on the to line and it doesn't actually
use up any space for the message mailbox
rows they don't have the correspondent
boolean set to true rather than null it
filters out all the null entries so yeah
so lessons learned with cloud spanner
setting up your schema is super
important particularly if you're putting
a lot of data into it you know it's
pretty easy to build and remove
secondary indexes but you are stuck with
your primary key index like you have to
rewrite
if you're changing your primary key it's
not magic like that and it's pretty
important to just sort of play around
with the schema to figure it out
so what challenges have we run into so
far I've been like singing its praises
and yeah you know no plan survives
contact with the enemy or the database
query planner so one challenge we ran
into is actually a spanner is too smart
for its own good for our use case I
guess your your use case may vary so
spanner has a lot of things or smarts in
the query planner to balance running a
lot of small transactional queries so
this is like the kind of thing that is
probably the you know ninety percent use
case it does things like if you run a
really big query it assumes that this
must be like an analytical query or
maybe like a you know back-end bulk task
indeed it will will be prioritize that
query and make sure that that query
takes a long time to run so it doesn't
get in the way of your transactional
queries but going back to our use case
as we mentioned the you know you've all
been on these horrible huge reply-all
threads and a lot of times you know
fortunately or unfortunately those
threads are the most important because
you know they're the ones where it's
like the collaboration story it really
gets tricky and you need to be able to
share some stuff but not other stuff and
we really need those to be answerable in
sort of a short enough amount of time
that it doesn't degrade the Gmail
experience and so what we were running
into was when we did the queries to span
out to fan out on those really big
threads it was you know not overwhelming
anything else but it was taking a long
time and there wasn't really a great way
to tell the query plan or hey this query
is really important you know go ahead
and do it and we tried some experiments
with you know finding out if they need a
bunch of queries we tried some
experiments with
you're doing like a little bit of
cashing in like Redis or something like
that using cloud memory store but we
just didn't find a thing that really
delivered the user experience we wanted
so that led us to our next database that
we're gonna chat about cloud BigTable
so cloud BigTable is actually it's based
on BigTable which is like you know right
now at this point a you know very
well-established Google technology it
has it sort of has a lot less
functionality than cloud span or cloud
datastore it's really just a key value
store or a sort of key value store let's
say and basically that means that
there's really two queries you can do to
it you can query for this particular
primary key give me the value or you can
do sort of lexicographic I'll have you
put off that word range queries and it
basically say hey give me all values for
keys between a and B or a a and a B and
so there it's like a pretty limited
query interface but the trade-off you
get here is that it's really really
simple and really really fast and so
they're basically each node you add to
cloud BigTable and it's another managed
database you can just like add and
remove nodes to your heart's desire and
you pay for more nodes get more
performance when it's night time you can
just like decrease the number of nodes
and sort of not pay for what you're not
using but basically each node you add
gives you ten thousand reads or writes a
second which is a lot of reads or writes
a second and basically the queries just
look like either put some data in for
this key or read some data for this key
or set of keys there's currently two
modes the mode that we use for this just
because it's like for our use case it's
it's you know not great if the feature
is unavailable but it's not like
business ending people can still get it
their action their streak box data which
is stored safely in cloud datastore by
there's one there's one mode that is
single zone availability has the concept
of a transaction within a particular row
and then there's another mode that is
multi zone replication you forego
transactions but even if one zone goes
down which is infrequent but happens you
can just access the data in another zone
and that it'll a synchronously replicate
after the zone comes back up so yeah so
cloud BigTable not a great tool for
every job but the best tool for some
jobs and we're actually using this in
production for querying this email
metadata index and let me show you sort
of what that looks like so here we've
got the output of CBT is the cloud
BigTable console and this is our
messages table and you can see there's
this concept of a a column family which
is sort of a set of data that's stored
together and we have one column family
for sort of each of those indexes that
we need to first the graph and so
they're you know for instance I was
showing you the message mailboxes table
and so we've got one column family
that's sort of this index for looking up
message mailboxes by the domain or by
the email and then also messages are
indexed by the message ID the RFC
message ID or the thread ID which lets
us do that sort of graph traversal and
the cool thing here is the big table API
is like completely asynchronous so we
basically when we're doing this graph
query we can just have a queue that's
just as soon as information comes back
sending out the next set of fetches and
that's all pipelined and can be you know
very much like sub-second so each lookup
is about 6 milliseconds so you can do a
lot of lookups before somebody notices
the delay other things here this is very
much sort of build it yourself so the
model in BigTable is just a string of
bytes to a string of bytes and so
we had to you know figure out our own
encoding that does lexicographic
encoding the way that we want there
there's a few libraries out there
there's one called orderly there's one
there's lens it's sort of partially
factored out at the HBase library so so
there's some tooling there but you still
need to like very much figure out your
own schema in your own encoding this was
a bit more developer intensive so
definitely don't recommend reaching for
this from the get-go but it is very very
fast and it really does what it says on
the tin so you know we're using a big
table for those lookups in production
six milliseconds you can do a whole
bunch of reads all at once
and it's like providing what we need and
so then sort of at the end of the day
just wanted to summarize sort of what we
already talked about in a convenient
flow chart flow chart and so kind of the
first question I'd ask if I were
reaching for a new database is how
developed is your project schema product
sort of whatever you want to however you
want to think about it if it's if you're
still in that sort of you know finding
you know product market fit or
experimenting with the with the project
then I think either cloud datastore
cloud fire stores probably where you
want to go basically they're you know
key things here it's got very flexible
schemas you just like set up the
documents and then you can you know
index a bunch of different ways after
the fact it's very easy to work with if
you're using a cloud fire store for a
new project you can actually use it in
firestorm mode get most of the same
thing or sorry in real-time mode get
most of the same benefits that we're
talking about and get sort of being able
to send stuff directly to your mobile or
web clients so I think that they're you
know if you're still figuring that out
that's a great choice oh also cloud fire
store and cloud datastore just have a
per operation billing model so if you're
not using it you're only paying for
storage which is like pretty cheap if
you're just getting started
whereas cloud BigTable or cloud spanner
are a per node pricing model so you're
paying hourly for each node that you
have setup so if you're just sort of
it's real cheap to get started with like
cloud firestore cloud datastore and then
yeah on the difference between those two
I start to jokingly put is it 2019 or
later but yeah really
cloud firestore datastore mode is just
cloud datastore but better they've
announced that they're gonna move
everybody to cloud firestore so if
you're starting a new project just start
with cloud firestore like it's I have
trouble envisioning a case in which you
actively want to go to datastore if
you're starting a new project so yeah so
if you're more certain of the needs for
your project if this is something where
either you know you're it's a new
technology for an established company or
product or if you're you're really
really certain of like your performance
needs and you've tested it out and have
a really good idea then that's when you
should probably reach for a cloud
BigTable or cloud spanner cloud spanner
is a lot nicer to work with if it has
data types it at sequel it has these
globally consistent transactions so
generally unless you know you're gonna
need to really really optimize those
like key value lookups and sort of build
things like this horrible reply-all
thread case definitely go with cloud
spanner or we actually built out this
index entirely on clouds or this
metadata indexing system entirely on
cloud spanner to start with I'm super
happy that we did even though we ended
up moving some of the workload to a
cloud BigTable because it informed a lot
of our decisions sort of gave us more
information on the use case and then
yeah if you just like really really need
that one specific tool then cloud
BigTable is probably what you should
reach for
[Music]